every year Human Rights Watch produces
an annual report detailing the most
oppressive places on earth this is not
where this year's report was supposed to
be launched with a focus this year on
China they plan to be in Hong Kong but
the head of the organisation ken Roth
was barred entry sadly as I arrived here
the Chinese government decided it didn't
want to let me in so even though I've
been able to enter Hong Kong freely
before this time for the first time they
blocked me instead he flew to the UN in
New York where he gave details of
China's repression that perhaps the
authorities there didn't want the world
to hear it goes beyond violence against
protesters in Hong Kong and the
detention camps in Xinjiang this is the
most severe period of repression that
we've seen in decades in China probably
going back to you know the Cultural
Revolution or an error like that Shin
Jang is the worst where you know a
million or more eager and Turkic Muslims
are in detention for forced
indoctrination basically to pressure
them to renounce Islam and and their
cultural traditions and even their
language at the end of the news
conference a Chinese diplomat had been
sitting at the back of the room came to
the front to condemn Human Rights Watch
the report is full of prejudices and
fabrications and ignore the facts
factual information provided by my
government repeatedly for all the years
it all raises the question is the
international community speaking out
enough I asked the spokesperson for the
UN secretary-general about the decision
to bar mr. Roth from entering Hong Kong
as a matter of principle we support the
right and the work of human rights
defenders throughout the world it's
comments like that that Human Rights
Watch say need to be much tougher they
say the United Nations and the entire
international community must denounce
failings on human rights by China and
others they say it's one of the few ways
to change behavior James BAE's al
Jazeera at the United Nations